[Musik]
australien
sven furrer auf abwegen
abseits der bekannten pfade
australien das land vor der superlative
das land ein kontinent der gesamten
nation so glücklich wie in down under
sie weiß alles ist tatsache für große
fahrzeuge aber macht das wirklich glück
mit wales 12 die 108 kilometer durch
aufschrauben
[Musik]
alice springs mini race vor der revanche
für den schotten
adriana b
ich bin sehr schmalen australien fakt
ist es wird heiß aber gerade so heiß mit
dem hanni krass mit uns bekannt alice
springs ist viel schlimmer als das mini
reichs startet im zentrum für australien
das heißt mitte im harz von roten
kontinent
[Musik]
nun ich bin eher so wie der baxi vor der
heimreise prof
denn wenn es nach mir
[Musik]
internationale studie sagt oberst bürger
australien die glückler stoffe wahl sind
ich habe es vor nicht vorstellen und
darum will ich die manche keine lehrer
lobten geld zum beispiel und wer sie die
glückstadt und verkommt zur wahl
[Musik]
bis vor sechs gebärde riesig das zeigen
die dimensionen von 12 300 kilometer in
st zusammen
beim ihnen kamerateam reise forscht
unter ganz kontinent vor der wir stehen
uns mehr von zahl platz und großstadt
über autobahnen und natur straße auf dem
wasser und abwasser
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
voll konzentriert ist längst überholt
als ich 14
[Musik]
ohne wachstum ersteindruck vor der krise
vor dem kontinent die unglaublich
wichtig das gefühl der grenzenlosigkeit
die stars der schlüssel zum glück
bitte mehr jemand erbeutet der beste
shooter verwaltete teil campbell und
schafft im outback in der wildnis mit
die vor australien
guten morgen ich suche campbell du bist
da freu mich ich bin sven vom schweizer
fernsehen
schön dich zu treffen du zeigst mir also
heute dein revier verstorbene der del
verschnitt arbeit ließ league und wirkt
unsicher
trotzdem schwierig ihn stolz dass alle
maschinen aus beckdorf australien und
ich darf eine hütte ein normaler
arbeitstag begleitet
laut bag ist nicht nur drei arbeitsort
von teil 1 mitbesitzer vor dem land das
land porsche sieht hunderte vorjahres in
den stamm der so genannte areal als
ranger auf schienen eigenen land
schaffen
jepsen drehe und machen stolz und
glücklich
[Musik]
das ist also das land eine familie
ja das ist mein land meine familie meine
onkel und tanten und meine großeltern
leben hier die häuser da drüben gehören
meinen tanten kleiner junge wuchs ich
hier draußen auf aus dieser erfahrung
heraus kann auch mein wunsch schwanger
zu werden
diese hügel rauf und runter zu krabbeln
das hat mich geprägt ich älter wurde
habe ich erkannt wie wichtig dieses land
für unser britschen es ist heutzutage
leben die aborigines doch meist in den
steckern und du willst raus aus der
stadt
da nach den ersten jahren ihr draußen
verbrachte ich fast mein ganzes leben in
der stadt
jetzt will ich wieder hier raus in die
landschaft meiner kindheit
das ist meine lebensaufgabe dieser
landschaft sorge zu tragen
dafür sind wir ja da nachdem ich meine
mutter verloren hatte
du hast deine mutter verloren ja vor
sechs oder sieben jahren
sie starb an krebs mir wurde klar dass
ich mein leben jetzt in die hand nehmen
muss und einen guten beruf brauche und
für meine familie sorgen zu können
jetzt habe ich wohl einen der besten
berufe die es gibt
[Musik]
the day ist verheiratet und hat zwei
kinder
im moment lebt er mit seiner familie in
alice springs china wunsch variabler
schiene sind gleich wie hier in der
natur aufwachsen
[Musik]
es ist der busch
duisburg zum ranger ist ausspruchs von
geprüften australiens hoch sie ist eine
von denen ganz wenige aborigines das es
geschafft hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weil ich hier fliegen meinst du die die
große die hier versucht die tauchen
meist nach einem größeren regen aus
wenn sie dich stechen mit dem musst du
hier in dieser hitze ist das trinkwasser
ja das ist trinkwasser für die wanderer
wir helfen mit dem schlauch wir schieben
ihn hier unter das netz
im sommer steht thermometer die zahl der
oft bis zu 50 grad
die natürliche wasserquelle sind
österreich tätige wassertanks ein schon
mangelware aber gerettet
da drüben auf dem ast siehst du sie
entdeckt
während der kamera bilder macht mir der
eu zu erfüllen
ich habe mich wohl zu viel fliegen
gestochen
dann bist du sicher dass es die fliegen
sind glaube ich schon an einigen stellen
schmerzen im gesicht
ich spüre dass mein gesicht langsam an
schwert weil ich mehr schweizer als zum
glück für apothekers antiallergikum so
schlecht habe ich mich dann 20 jahren
hier draußen noch nie gefehlt
wenn du willst kann ich dich zur rangers
ich kann selbst fallen
bist du sicher es ist nur diese
lockerheit so unangenehm aber ich kann
sich alleine zurück fahren die
dreharbeiten mit dem dms überbracht und
er bestätigte kind ranger stations vorn
wenigstens hat er es funkt grad
vielen dank für den tollen ausflug sei
vorsichtig auf dem heimweg war wirklich
schön mit dir und pass auf dich auf
so blieb mir nichts anderes übrig war
michael einzig auf der schlacht im
outback vorbereitet
eigentlich bin ich ausgegangen dass in
der wildnis giftschlange mini
griechisches sorge haben sie jetzt von
mir sahen stellen ausstrahle
die sind so aggressiv als für stocker
dass ich grauenhaft und das hat
millionen abermillionen dass ich das
schwimmen wissen
[Musik]
die startflagge machen wie vor steinig
und das ist immer noch übertragen
das könne vor der wahl ist der bagger
nicht
[Musik]
denn versichert dass er gehört der heime
chancen lachen sei der mann am telefon
zur strahlung bekämpfen
bestes beispiel dafür
[Musik]
ich bekomme hier ein erster eindruck und
faszination ausstrahlen ausmacht
die vita und das gefühl von grenzenloser
[Musik]
dennoch ein schiff stach pflege
zurückzog
aber die breite kritisch bleibe schlaufe
an init will
[Musik]
männer erst große reise dank und noch
vor mittag alle schon 340 kilometer auf
die zahlen
[Musik]
ja
zum 1
unbekannte heilige berg vorzüglich
vorbei was mich interessiert sind
abmahnungen
ob sie vor der australische geschäft
mittlerweile eine über diese
kilometerzahl und langsam wird es dunkel
einzig seitlich weit und breit ist wie
im krieg
das modell tankstelle und ein paar
blätter 105
adriana von der tankstelle hat für uns
hier angerufen und zimmer resümiert ich
hatte nicht angerufen aber das kriegen
wir schon hin
und dir genießt das feierabendbier heute
nicht wirklich
hallo wie geht's denn er hat mich
angerufen und zimmer reserviert nicht
keine ahnung wen sie angerufen hat aber
sie sollte zimmer für uns reservieren
ich habe keine reservation aber ich habe
freie zimmer für eine nacht nur eine
nacht
[Musik]
weltkrieg ist noah verreisen die nach
einer langen tag und erforscht und
ertrag hits genesis holz beschäftigt
nach das und vor allem es
[Musik]
aber so gut
am anderen morgen noch bekanntschaft mit
dem zorneding gobert und
schienenbesetzungen travelport ischer
typ knorrig und unterhaltsam kehrt nicht
nur das pop als konter in der motel one
übernachtet im chat konz dorf
[Musik]
ich bin der sekretär der grad der
feuerwehrkommandant und zuständig für
die stromversorgung und das wasser
angeht
ich mache alles vom chef bis zum
hilfsarbeiter über nötig helfe ich in
der küche putze die hotelzimmer man muss
wirklich vielseitig sein
ich sitze nicht einfach im büro hinter
meinem computer und habe nach acht
stunden feierabend sieben tage die woche
24 stunden im einsatz so dorf ist der
glückliche einverstanden
ich finde wir können uns sehr glücklich
schätzen dass wir so viel platz haben
alle dieselbe sprache sprechen und alle
die gleichen chancen im leben
wir haben einen gemeinschaftssinn und
helfen einander im outback ist dieser
gemeinschaft sehen besonders ausgebildet
nur wenn wir einander helfen können wir
hier draußen überleben will ohne
klimatisch die mittagshitze schmidt spd
hat als erstes das pub greift auch in
anderen bezirken menschen sport billig
diese schlussendlich im besitz von ganze
dorf ist
ich sage dir hier draußen zu leben prägt
den charakter
der vereinfachte hoch in der
wellblechhütte da drüben steht unser
generator der das ganze dorf versorgt
ich zeige dir wo ich lebe
das ist das einzige stück rasen im
ganzen dorf und das ist mein schloss mit
swimmingpool
denn alleine hier draußen zu leben
du bist nie wirklich alleine geht los
ich bin ständig beschäftigt mit alten
unterhaltsarbeiten im dorf du hast ja
viele leute mit dem du plaudern kannst
aber ein richtig persönliches gespräch
gibt es da doch nicht nein weißt du hier
draußen musste mich selbstständig leben
kann wenn du das nicht kannst hältst es
nicht aus im outback musste wirklich
hart im nehmen sein
wenn nicht reibt sich die wildnis und
den wahnsinn die hitze die fliegendreck
[Musik]
betrieb zu allem dazu nur ein flugblatt
auf dem graffiti jungfräulichen vor
rauber im park betty and had just
happened und verzehr musikgeschäft
piloten vor dem lokal airline d'italia
noch business mit frischen blick ins
outback
[Musik]
ein pilot in verbier und rezession schon
damals aber ziemlich vielseitig und
flexibel sie ja so ist es
du musst wirklich vielseitig sein du
musst eine gute mechanikerin sein muss
gut mit menschen umgehen können
es gibt viele touristen die hier
vorbeikommen an der rezeption genau dann
kocht dort ja klar das ist schon okay so
wir machen alle alles langweilig wird es
bestimmt nie d'italia verzählt mir eher
freundlich pilot xc90 alte dame sind
eigentlich nur mein sommerferien
hast du schon einmal in der schweiz ja
ich habe ein jahr lang in der schweiz
gelebt nein wirklich wo ich bin in
wohlen zur schule gegangen und habe an
drei unterschiedlichen orten gelegt in
einem kleinen dorf namens bett fiel in
muri und den han
[Musik]
ich lebe in zug also in bar
ach da bin ich jeden tag mit dem
motorrad durch gefahren hast du dort
eine schule besucht ja ich habe ein
austauschjahr gemacht nachdem ich die
schule in australien abgeschlossen hatte
und ich habe in der schweiz fußball
gespielt
der frauenfußball ist in der schweiz auf
einem unglaublich hohen niveau
ich habe viel gelernt du hast fußball
gespielt ja wir wollen dann trägst du
sicher weiße socken wie alle akw nein
ich habe wieder auf schwarze socken
umgestellt d'italia macht mir sorgen
wenn die welle fliege chemie zu meinem
nächsten sie mit kamerateam ich
begeistert ich weniger
[Musik]
die thalia meint der blick von oben das
ist australisch klick als kabinettschef
[Musik]
der pflegebereich er ein riesiges einzel
china ist die playstation erfahren fast
so gross wie der kanton tessin mit der
eigenen lande besten
clayton oldfield und china ford shale
sind besitzer von zwei richtige outback
bürger hertie scholler beifahrer du bist
der sohn kleid
schön dich kennenzulernen ich bin's wenn
mir geht's gut danke und wie ist das
leben auf der kleinen farm kann mich
nicht beklagen
das ist mein vater schon freue mich wie
geht's gut
und wie sieht's aus trocken und heiß ist
und es ist trocken das stimmt und viel
arbeit
wir müssen die wasserlöcher verzweifeln
und die zäune müssen repariert werden
klingt es so habt ihr also arbeit für
mich keine sorge wir finden schon was
für dich
ich bin jetzt unterwegs auf - und noch
immer australische glück einen job die
100 kilometer hinter mir und jetzt benni
verkleiden station
[Musik]
ich begleite begleitet viel sie
generationen bewirtschaftet die familie
die in typischer stralis form mit ihm
auf der form so gross wie der kanton
tessin wie ich's lieber auf dem land wo
der nächste nachbar vertriebs kilometer
wieder wackelt
auf ihrem land zwischen dort vieles
rinde und zusätzlich hatten die haare
hall will die russen die probiere
beliebte zahnarzt liebe mithilfe
zweirädrigen sowas ist der plan
dort drüben sie ist eine staubwolke
das sind die pferde wir fahren gleich
über meinem vater zu helfen
seinem vater ja dort siehst du das licht
seines motorrads er fährt mit einigem
abstand zur erde
er treibt die pferde darüber und wir
schneiden ihnen dann den weg
[Musik]
es sind praktisch videos maximal zwei
bis drei mal im jahr zusammen leben
[Musik]
als ich vor stetig zu so dass wir gerade
jetzt jetzt klick zusammen
[Musik]
die tiere und natur bestimmen slama
verformt das erinnert mich an meine
kindheit ist
[Musik]
begleiten trend micros vor der harder
der grund ist dass die tonnen rohstahl
besitzer in paris verkauft begleiten
letzteres ganzes jahr in kanada als
pferdeflüsterer es bilde inso moment
konnte weil haare von kohle cowboy zum
vorschein
das ist noch ganz aufgedreht um
zusammentreten
ich muss sie zuerst beruhigen ich spiele
ein wenig mit dir rum und versuche die
bindung zu ihr aufzubauen
sie muss wieder vertrauen zu gewinnen
mit hilfe von rausch länder blocher für
staaten die schreckhaftigkeit so tut als
ross auf den transport vorbereiten
bedeutet für dich glück mit pferden zu
arbeiten
es ist eine leidenschaft für mich ich
reite seit ich zwei jahre alt und 10
habe ich mein erstes wildes pferd
gezählt findet pferden aufgewachsen habe
mit ihm viele schöne dinge erlebt
ich fühlte mich pferden immer nahe
ich liebe es mit ihm zu arbeiten und
neue ziele mit ihnen zu erreichen
was ist eine leidenschaft du darfst dich
nicht verkrampfen sei so wie du bist
dann nimmt sie dich an hast du erfahren
mein vater hat er 20 jahre lang hatte
einfach angst du musst also einzige
vertrauen gewinnen lasse dich
kennenlernen
sie soll sich mit beiden nüstern riechen
kann denn jedes nasenloch verarbeitet
unterschiedliche informationen und halte
sie an der kurzen leine
dann kannst du sie besser kontrollieren
vergiss nicht zu lächeln
[Musik]
wirklich extrem woche und karg 100 km
staffel trat sie zusammen
es ist lange sisyphus-arbeit die schüler
entstand worden ob ich im wirklichen
halver weise aber der kleine nick clegg
ich bin einsam
also hier bauen wir ein gatter gerade
schweißen verstrebungen für ein gatter
brauchen wir die türkei der kann nicht
schnell in die eisenwarenhandlung die
ist 800 kilometer weit weg wir haben
hinten raus unseren eigenen zappa
sperrmüll und altmetall den durchsuchen
wir wenn wir etwas brauchen musste zu
helfen wissen
alles wird wiederverwendet nichts wird
weggeworfen
das sind
[Musik]
zu kleiden hat große plan kramer mit
schiene frau violet vormonat
leider ist die ehe geschieht tritt unter
träume ist somit platz die beide sehen
glauben jetzt die innenstadt wieder weg
vor ihm
ich weiß dass ich das thema oder kleid
nicaragua
darum probiert es mit dem alu cross
bruch muss ganz schön schwierig seien
hier im outback eine frau kennenzulernen
ja du läufst nicht gerade täglich einer
über den weg erst recht keine meisten
schweizer gern touristinnen die auswahl
ist bescheiden
du musst einfach jede chance nutzen
seine freundin nein zur zeit bin ich
single in dem zusammenhang werde mir das
lied vom outback bewusst manche handy
zwar die große freiheit gewartet presse
schwierigen partner zu finden
lock mails klicken
[Musik]
der bus für 2003 also fünf jahre
aber die grünen sind nicht kaputt und
mit der holländerin krone aufsetzen
[Musik]
die snacks ziel
ich stell gerti es abgemacht mit weniger
als 100 bewohner wenn es nach dem willen
von der politik gange war hänge der
ländlich villa für 100 saya hsh die
größere bekanntheit als siebter oder
melbergen erlangt kann ich etwas fragen
ich habe keine zeit wirklich nur zwei
minuten
stimmt es dass er gern mal beinahe die
hauptstadt von australien wurde
wie kam es dazu ich weiß es nicht ich
kenne nur die bildlegende vor dem bild
trüben
das ist das foto und die bildlegende der
zug
das sind die minister und was machen die
im wasser das zitat um war das wasser
von der getty zu lassen weiß nicht ich
könnte wirklich keine geschichte dazu
erzählen
okay das sind minister vor der
australische provinz sie hätten in 203
entstand ort führen gemeinsame
hauptstadt gehört in melbourne sind
damals rivale ex minister eine
standortsuche unabhängig zwischen den
zwei großen feierlichkeiten geschichte
getty entschieden will eine suite von
riese bahnlinie xiii und andere sich
minister vorsieht neben nachteilig fühlt
will der getty ein paar wenige kilometer
metern an melbourne ist am art revival
von sydney
[Musik]
magic damals für es anderes macht wann
ihr kind entschieden
oder wissen sie es
[Musik]
der heutige hauptstadt traf ich meine
gesprächspartner der urs wälterlin
arisch korrespondent von schweizer radio
und fernsehen und leipzigs jahr in
australien ist ein künstler wie heinz
klewe brasilia in brasilien haben mir
sind staatlich besitzen kein branche
allofs vom sie es wirklich leid in front
vor dem parlament
das war super zu spielen es gibt grünes
land so groß ist um so wenig aubergine
politik weiß im vergleich zum wurf aus
nis outfit eher zur schaufel als zur
stadtpolitik aber bereits schon mit dem
handy und krawatte australien trotz der
manchmal politik für abgemacht war
ammann zeigt guten morgen herr graf wie
geht's morgen ich bin zwar sehr gut wir
haben es gefunden
es ist nicht so schwierig so ein
riesiges gebäude zu finden
es ist ein hügel versteht
jahrhundert achtet kann man das programm
am gebäude eröffnet hat ist ihr stück
gebäude mit weniger als 1 million
schweizer franken kostet das ist das
parlament 150 repräsentanten die
regierung setzt auf dieser seite
die opposition da drüben und die kleinen
parteien irgendwo hier und im gegensatz
zur schweiz geht es hier sehr laut zu
und her
das ist ein teil unserer kultur
wir gehen direkt miteinander um das ist
ganz typisch australisch wir sehen es in
diesem parlament die debatten hier sind
berühmt berüchtigt
schlicht unanständig aber die realität
ist dass dies einfach zu unserer kultur
gehört was sind die großen themen im
parlament zur zeit
es gibt verschiedene große team aber das
mit abstand wichtigste sind die
arbeitsplätze
seit die rohstoffpreise einbrechen unter
investment boom abkühlt müssen wir
schauen wie wir arbeitsplätze schaffen
können das ist eine wirklich harte
debatte als ich mich auf die sendung
vorbereitet lass ich viel über das lucky
country
wie sehen sie das nun gewisse leute
übersetzenden ausdruck lucky country als
das land das schwein gehabt hat und so
zu wohlstand kann
wir hatten aber nie einfach schwein
wir hatten stets auch probleme zu
bewältigen eine große herausforderung
zur zeit ist die wirtschaftslage unsere
arbeitslosenquote steigt
wir haben mit dem rohstoffboom einiges
unsere konkurrenzfähigkeit eingebüßt wir
müssen das glück wieder in die hand
nehmen wir nehmen die welt so wie sie
ist
wir machen unser eigenes glück indem wir
uns den realitäten anpassen und die
probleme pragmatisch anpassen
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt wird familie walter
linner der fahrer aufs land
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt größer
der us-major entschiedener jungen von
meinem büro auf träumt betrieb der
journalistin gerät erhoben
das ist krieg mit hund moritz und jetzt
produktion der us und christine henrich
vor über 20 jahren australien kennen und
lieben klären mit denen damaligen
partner sind in australien exil und
schickt zur falle geworden
es ist liebe auf der spree
ja das ist sozusagen ein es ist also das
grundstück das der karabag generation
das 40 verhindern und die form sind
einem grundstück insgesamt sind sie
ungefähr 30 hektar dann hätte aber das
grundstück betritt ist dass das haus hat
er sofort gefunden und es kann alles
selber menschlichen jobs dem grundstück
gefangen
wieviel strahlung das machen zuerst
einmal kleine wohnwagen hingestellt und
zwar über das zusätzlich dann haben wir
große wohnwagen angestellt wird familie
gewachsen ist und wenn ist dem wohnwagen
halte sie jedoch sehr haltbar unterricht
unter null in der regel meist mit am
start steht im heiß kann sogar mit hat
strahlt sie und deshalb wurde der strom
und das user verborgene wurzeln sind
jetzt hier meine wurzeln sind in der
schweiz ich beschließe ich bin der
schweizer straße lag ich erkläre den
verlauf und sagen du bestritten wo die
menschen sind wo du lebst wunsch jetzt
in der schweiz oder in der nachbarschaft
herum gesprochen dass der us besuch von
schweizer fernsehen also seinen worten
ist der gewerbesteuer ist eine ganz
normale nachbarschaft party barbeque und
das findet im chat in gartenhütte staat
typisch australisch soll das sind die
luft
hallo mich schön dich kennenzulernen
bei diesem heißen australischen wetter
habe ich jemals so einen durst sehr gut
das gefällt mir
vielen dank
und nochmals danke für die einladung
[Musik]
eine typische typisch dass alles
dominiert wird von einer sache ist das
ist das meer ist wirklich meinert und
sogar 20 europäische stoxx sie das bei
sonniger part ist frauen und man eine
strikt trennt sie sind man muss sie noch
eine ebene nötig sind eine verspätung
war es ein regelbuch xi und handel
teresa hatte bitte davon freude der bi
sie dürfen sogar mit fremden flirter
hallo ich bin's wenn wie hast du's wenn
möglich danke er ist anders eigentlich
rede ich nicht mit leuten deren namen
ich nicht kennen
nachdem eigentlich sehr wichtig sehe man
so ein buch das in kürze sachen
passieren
für kuren angefragt collectors dass ich
noch nicht
[Musik]
es würde der länge und der lustige aber
irgendwann beschließt der kollege vom
news walter lindl brian cox mit zügen
der beats bringen die erste lektion ist
der ort der knopf von unten hoch durchs
auge zu behalten
oben drüber und drunter oben durch
wieder runter jetzt sieht es aus wie
nacht ist also der zahn prof
ich bezeichne es als 60 jahren zum gaudi
von der ganzen nachbarschaft screen
hohen wie sie schweiz so und dann durch
und un-truppen drum wieder unten durch
und zurück hier drücken noch ein wenig
runter
hier muss ich jetzt zurückziehen
[Musik]
weiter geht's in blue mountains nach
katong stunden
[Musik]
das start gehabt wie erhöhte andere
destinationen vom tourismus die gastro
märkten natur immer nutzt wichtiges
kapital für australien
graffiti ururenkel von bekannte england
in der vorrunde tauchte sie mit
klebstoffen natur bewundert und den idee
kommt bald verhandelt
[Musik]
ich lehre schräge aber sehr
sympathischer vorgekommen du siehst aus
wie bist du denn unterwegs menschen
bestiegen in diesen kleidern den mount
everest
das ist ein wild enkel von bekannten
charles darwin begründer der
evolutionstheorie sich von der schutz
vor bedrohte art und warum lässt du mit
dem fahrrad unterwegs
ich versuche meinen ökologischen
fußabdruck so klein wie möglich zu
halten
ich will sabine wasserstrahl ihrer
verschiedenen bekannten psycho jones
torhüter noch einen lehrer china
ururenkel chris zeigt mir die glückliche
wentworth vor katumba die gegend um 1806
ist im rahmen von amerika expedition
erkundet bleibt wie alle damals fest
dass gott mensch und natur schäfer hat
hier an dem ort hat aber das waldbild er
wandert die hier größeren diese
fantastischen aussicht hier entstanden
die ersten kritischen gedanken die
später in der faszinierenden frage
mündeten
was sind wir haben wir vom affen ab oder
wurden wir von gott erschaffen
charles darwin hier seine autobiografie
sein denken fest geschrieben meine
goldene regel lautet schenkel jenen
fakten besonders viel aufmerksamkeit die
deinen überzeugungen widersprechen
das war seine goldene regeln ich denke
das ist das wichtigste dass wir von ihm
lernen können
überleg dir was er da sagt dass es
gewalt selbstverständlich neigen wir
dazu alles zu ignorieren was unseren
überzeugungen widerspricht damals
grundhaltung macht das leben absolut
faszinierend denn plötzlich hatte ich
alles zu interessieren
nichts ist sakrosankt du musst alles
hinterfragen das ist wohl das wichtigste
das ich von ihm gelernt haben
er hat also viel verändert du hast auch
viel verändert du hast dein leben
verändert etwas darüber
viele von uns hatten schon einmal dunkle
zeiten geblieben ich auch ich habe
versucht mir das leben zu nehmen
große sache natürlich danach nie mehr
derselbe sein
davor war ich nur an geld und
materiellem erfolg interessiert
ich merkte aber dass mehr geld nicht das
geben konnte was ich brauche
darum wurde und versuchte ein fröhliches
optimistisches leben zu finden nicht
mehr nach materiellem reichtum zu
streben
[Musik]
für christa goetsch galt als werber
gemacht es klingt aber hätten
in der natur kommen hier wird's nass und
wir laden alles ab
rucksack runter und neopren anzug
anziehen
das ist der erste sprung war das wasser
nicht tief ist musste rückwärts springt
was rückwärts rückwärts also ist es
sicher nein überhaupt nicht
ist das schön hier
hier gibt es süßwasser hunger wollen wir
anfangen
ja klar
sie können nicht ganz schlimm zwacken
wirklich ganz schlimm zweiten lass dich
nicht erwischen
er versucht gerade jetzt bist du
er kann mit den scheren weit nach hinten
greifen versucht die hand so flach wie
möglich zu halten
wir machen es so ich halte ihn
vorsichtig mit dem stock und du kannst
ihn sicher in die hand nehmen das hat
ihn gut fest nicht wie und jetzt die
hand ganz flach sehr gut
das ist ein australischer süßwasser und
ein handy
das war knapp
ich sagte schon ergebe der einen
abschiedsgruß es ist beeindruckend mit
was für andere begeistert und
unbeschwertheit christoph in der natur
begegnet
[Musik]
der kreis ist dass man mit positiver
erraten es in der natur der menschen
finden nachhaltiger effekt erreichen als
wenn man mit moralisieren aufschlags
gewisse macht
[Musik]
ungewöhnlich hoch
mit dem großteil der schüler dass die
punkte zu behalten
haben
sehr gut gemacht du warst super
das lichtspiel wunderschön
family darin lebt in die ortschaft glenn
beck krist natur freak city frau jackie
pr beraterin sein und bezeichnet sich
selber als sieger ihres ist der perfekt
kompromiss
zwei schritte in ihrem sitzplatz vor der
regelrechte uhr wollte
[Musik]
wir passen denn natur freak und
pr-berater dieser stadt sammer auf der
splitt center chris und jackie es kurios
war dem orchester merkte aber bald das
schiff 2 gefunden was sich bestens
ergänzen
wie steht es nun mit dem umweltschutz in
australien muss schwierig sein alle
reden nur vom wirtschaftsboom die
umweltverschmutzung ist groß australien
hat einen größeren ökologischen
fußabdruck als die meisten europäischen
länder eigentlich als die meisten länder
der welt
wir könnten noch vieles verbessern
ökologisch sind wir ein weniger
glückliches land klimawandel für euch
erwiesen
für mich es muss dringend etwas
geschehen
meiner ansicht nach australien hat
bereits ein extremes klima wir haben
zwar nicht die tiefen temperaturen wie
ihr in europas aber wir haben die extrem
hohen temperaturen und heftige stürme
das wird immer schlimmer und
unangenehmer nahrungsmittel werden
teurer
es wird viele andere folgen haben aber
ich denke wir menschen ticken halt so
solange du nicht direkt betroffen ist
oder besonders selbstlos und dann nimmst
du nichts gegen den klimawandel
[Musik]
iris ziel ist man sie und der rest natur
zu begeistern und nicht wie andere sind
stunden vor dem computer zu verbringen
[Musik]
ich darf im all morgendliche ritual wie
sie und schnell merken dass möchten sind
kennen oliver ihrem wagen haben sie
werden die aus der hand frisst
setz dich hierher wir müssen alle ruhig
sei dann kommen sie grund hat das ganz
ruhig sein
geht wieder eine sorge er kam zurück
du bist geduldig ja ich bin all den
vogel flüsterer vogel flüstert hunger
auflistet
wie fühlt sich das an sven großartig
ich versuche jeden tag zu beginnen
die idee dahinter wenn du mit einer
positiven gefühlen den tag startet kommt
alles gut
das bild würde den große charles darwin
voller china urenkel vor dem schweizer
journalist zeigt wie wenig das projekt
klick naturfilme
[Musik]
ich moment arena im tropischen norden
von australien
[Musik]
die gegend ist berühmt-berüchtigt für
salzwasser krokodil immer wieder kunst
zu tödlicher unfall nicht wenige welte
am liebsten die gefährliche jahres rote
weekend mensch und krokodil sammle aber
ein aber das weiß ist journalist
krokodil forscher und wissenschaftler im
croke park in darwin als er zu beladen
ihres krokodil zeit war in den letzten
acht in krokodile spor gestorben es war
das größte krokodil das jedem hafen
runden gefahren wurde
es ist also ein ganz spezielles team für
transport und mitarbeiter von charly
borra fixiert war schon länger
letzte nacht begegnet zu einem tier bei
einem romantischen mondschein bat ich
habe noch nie von so nah gesehen wenn
ich ein tier von dieser größe erwischt
hast du 0 schossen zu berlin 0
aber sie sind ein teil unseres lebens
ein wichtiger teil stimmt die menschen
hier norden müssen mit diesen tieren
leben
es geht also darum der population so zu
kontrollieren dass die menschen die
tiere akzeptieren du kennst das von den
wölfen in der schweiz
die bauern wollen sie nicht weil sie
ihre schafe reisst die krokodile fressen
wie büffel menschen sie fressen alles
unsere herausforderung besteht darin die
öffentlichkeit dazu zu bringen dass sie
diese tiere wollen wir mussten die tiere
also irgendwie wertvoll machen das kann
tourismus sein oder die zucht
wir haben jetzt ein nachhaltiges
programm wir haben zahlen die touristen
in unserem bank wir haben eine
fleischindustrie exportiere gruppe die
leute und das schafft arbeitsplätze
krokodil ist also wird es wenn das ist
unser inkubator da haben wir
normalerweise bis zu 12.000 leider bist
du zum ende der prozessoren aber du
kannst mit helfen wir tun sie ins becken
sie kommen mit 68 kleinen szenen aus dem
rhein
das ist unglaublich sie finden immer den
empfindlichsten teil eines fingers 1
vorne oben siehst du den kleinen weißen
da das ist der 1
alle zähne sind schon da
ich habe kein kugelschreiber dabei die
beißen sich problemlos blut
unglaublich die haut ist so weich
kaum zu glauben dass so etwas niedliches
mal sechs meter lang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die zuchtstation von rocco die box
öffentlichkeit gesperrt die schorle und
justine mir sind das großes männliches
die arriva
es wird ihn so dass krokodile setzte
olic nach sturgis versuchen aber bist du
sicher dass da nur 1 trainings sucht
alles passt auf wenn es hochkommt
es wird sehr schnell sein vor wenigen
minuten lief erzählt es gibt keine
chance wenn dieses krokodil attackiert
hoffen wir machen das nicht zum letzten
mal
das krokodil probiert chiffriert in dem
es sich um die eigene achse
hermann hess probleme achtung seriöser
partner gemacht die so ganz wohl ist
es ist ziemlich überlegen
sie sind 50 zentimeter von mir begrenzt
und ich habe eigentlich das eigentlich
nur dazu erhöht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir binden ihm jetzt das maul zu das
krokodil hat unglaubliche kraft beim zug
essen aber fast keine kraft das mode zu
öffnen
natürlich nur recht
es ist ganz ruhig jetzt aber sie haben
diese ausbrüche sehr schnell erschöpft
müssen sich erholen
plötzlich bäumen sie sich wieder auf
wenn er sich benimmt können wir
glücklich sein aber wir müssen immer
aufpassen
der hals des krokodils ist zu stark wir
können es problemlos ziehen
hass auf das bein auf jung
er studierte sie an der box nach allem
was ich aber erlebte ich mir klar dass
man so lässt ihren mit seiner kraft nur
so transportieren
und so bringt lied von charlie das
krokodil
[Applaus]
höfer australier vertiefend krokodil
dank dem journalisten im team sind die
tiere in der innen attraktion über
arbeitsplatz schaffen
da wird natur und mensch
aufeinandertreffen können konflikte
entstanden
ich weiß wer man muss akzeptieren dass
es die absolut sicherheit nicht geht und
probiere mit der natur zum eklat
auf meine frage ich mich schon auf
einige arbeiter sollen mit die durch die
gegend forderte müller
[Musik]
die legendären strecke ist nur in der
druck hat sich bevor man denn wenn es
wenig wasser führen
[Musik]
egal der strecke blieben stiegen bereits
charakterbildend nicht mehr
[Musik]
die frau eine viertelstunde weniger weg
und ich muss jetzt was nachfolger finden
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin inspektionen
das ist der vorteil von endlose und
mancher laut beck ich gehe einfach von
der straße ab und fahren und die natur
ihr zugedachten wieder weg forderte
zivilisation war das in der schweiz nur
möglich
[Musik]
die endlose wie tine vom kontinent
center praktisch mancher trainer sind
bereits auf der suche nach nahrung
durchs land zogen
mit der ersten siedler vor 220 jahren
von der uni wunder diesem gleichgewicht
gründe
so
also das privatgrundstück
ich nehme ich sie richtig
ich habe mit dem level pauline ob
gemacht mit china familie im kalkarer
camp david krejci stamm vor dem china
zusammen mit dem willigt australien vor
der ureinwohner keine lehre in den
natur- und mit der natur
gerade mal gefragt hallo josip colina
sein
ja das bin ich ich bin es wäre schön
dich kennenzulernen
fantastisch bei dem wetter sehr schön
und angenehm kühl seit zwei wochen
wer bist du denn freut mich die nächsten
zwei tage im busch zusammen mit der
familie vom netz also alles was du hier
im camping ist kannst du ohne bedenken
trinken nun schleunigst lass dir einfach
in ruhe die kommen nicht um dich zu
beißen die haben besseres zu tun als sie
einfach vorbei ziehen und es gibt keine
probleme kennt hier um das du nicht
essen
das ist meine einzige regel hier wir
leben in einer symbiotischen beziehung
mit der natur lingus kommen vorbei wilde
truthähne neulich steckt ein strauß sein
kopf ins auto rein das ist also deine
unter toll aus
so wie wenn du auf diesem bett schläft
fühlst du dich in meinem kennt musst du
dich wie ein familienmitglied fühlen
mit diesem respekt behandeln wir uns
hier groß die nächsten tage gehöre ich
zu deiner familie
du bist mein bruder großartig bis später
[Musik]
sturm vor dem china hart umkämpft als
sie zuvor ihren traditionelle land ohne
kontrahenten evtl zum hirte vor ihrem
stammes landberg holen
mit den verschiedenen kein finanziert
aber unterhalt vor dem land es ist eine
große ehre für meine familie die hüter
dieses landes zu sein ich zeige dir
heute wie glücklich sind
ich sehe es die an
hier musste einfach glücklich aufwachen
am morgen wenn nicht bist du tot
der liebste im himmel das holz dass
meine tochter angelina trägt ist von
großer spiritueller bedeutung für uns
bereichern sich heute und ich auf
unserem land willkommen
wir holen dich in den schützenden rauch
damit den nichts passiert und braucht
wird alle schlechten geister vertreten
die auf mein land bringt die werden hier
im feuer bleiben danach werden wir einen
fantastischen tag haben
wir verwenden das holz von drei
unterschiedlichen bäumen grabosch und
papier hinten bauen dieser rauch reinigt
uns dann nimmt alles böse von uns es ist
nicht wirklich gut
ja wunderbar jetzt muss ich das feuer
ersticken
damit wir den rauch richtig einhalten
können
kann bei kindern vor
nicht so gut ist
[Musik]
wir verbringen den nachmittag an laut
große war traditionell wissen jean david
k angelina unter simon kennen alle
pflanzen und tieren ergangen
[Musik]
simon hat verschiedene fort erklärt wenn
man baramundi fischt mit arista minarik
bürger leben kannst du mir helfen ja wie
muss ich die route bewegen wenn wir den
kader ein wulst machst du immer
ruckartig 123 mit kleinen außen
dazwischen dann sieht es aus wie ein
verwundeter fisch der nicht mehr richtig
schwimmen können das lockt in warmen die
er will einen einfachen fall wenn wir
glück haben willst du uns heute abend
alle satt machen
ich versuche mein bestes es klang wie
latein klingt mir der erste schwung
denn hoch die das netz
langsam nicht ausrutschen
so ein lauf hier über ok geschafft hat
macht starterklasse und berechnet wenn
das verbieten
auf dem mist von blacky bilde
jedes mal wenn wir uns in der natur
bedienen sollen während ihr dem fisch
unseren respekt und danken dem land das
es uns ermöglicht hat essen nach hause
zu bringen
es ist ganz einfach wir nehmen unseren
schweiß aus der achselhöhle und
streichen ihn auf den boden wie eine
unterschrift was sagen wir danke dass
wir diesen fluss hinter unserem haus
haben wir versprechen gut nach
hinzuschauen und natur in china so
privat und china apotheke hier vieles
was er verschiedene familie betrieben
das ist der baum den wir suchen sehr gut
gegen entzündungen und keller ich
befestige dem plastiksack hier und du
kannst ihr helfen die medizin zu können
wird deine familie ist mein bruder du
hältst den ast so und ziehst einfach die
blätter vor fahrer von mclaren sieht
über 60 jahre auf dem kontinent mit acht
vor der wiese siegers inter bridges in
ihrem eigenen land an antrag wurde
du hast dein schicksal in die hand
genommen und etwas aufgebaut
warum erschaffen dass nur so wenige grip
ich schlage dich ware machen
grundsätzlich so wenig menschen etwas
aus ihrem leben
nicht nur ich denke mein volk muss jetzt
krankl verpasst
wir wurden 250 jahre lang kolonialisiert
wir müssen begreifen dass der kontinent
nicht mehr nach uns geht
er gehört den schwarzen und weißen
leider haben wir eine weiße regierung
und virgin hieß müssen uns den weißen
anpassen
viele haben alkoholprobleme
sie ziehen in die städte und verlieren
das traditionelle wissen ich denke das
ist doch das hauptproblem
oder wenn deine menschen den stolz das
selbstvertrauen
in allen andern die von den weißen
erobert worden lebten stolze menschen
schon zu lange unterdrückt dieses trauma
veränderte das denken der menschen
dümpelte 250 jahre lang in den
schwersten herum die uns die regierung
zu geworfen hat jetzt sagen sie hey wir
wollen die besten zurück sie hat aber
nicht gemerkt dass wir gar nie gelernt
haben zu schwimmen bevor man den
menschen die schwimmwesten wecken muss
man ihnen das schwimmen sonst trinken
sie
lucio hat mir nie baramundi es kostet
und welche selbst das beste stück
das filetstück warum für mich meine
kinder und ich essen den kopf und den
schwanz
der kopf ist für den ältesten mann am
tisch und der schwanz für die älteste
frau darum habe ich dir vorher gesagt
sag nicht überstürzt ich will dieses
oder jenes stoppen denn im lauf seines
lebens wirst du den ganzen fisch essen
und endet alles zu seiner zeit und
nichts überstürzen
wenn jemand battles ich will dies ich
will jenes bekommt er es erst recht
nicht dann gebe ich dir also den kopf
simon willst deinen kopf den großen oder
kleinen nimm du den großen papa ich
nehme den klein
[Musik]
du bist als weiße australierin mit einem
abrutschen verheiratet wie hast du all
diese regeln gelernt das war ein
langsamer prozess lebens familie hat
mich sehr herzlich aufgenommen und
akzeptiert
sie haben nie gesagt so musst du es
machen
sie gaben mir zeit zu lernen vor allem
in dem sie mir dinge zeigt ich mache
manchmal etwas schwer von begriff aber
sie waren geduldig und großzügig uns
natürlich konnte mir helfen zum beispiel
bei den tischmanieren die ungewohnt
waren
wisst ihr noch was wir in der schweiz
sagen vor dem essen
es ist das anders wenn wir selber
gefangen hat und das ich sehe verein
übrigens sehr gut ich bin hier waren der
verwender nach strich und faden und
hinter dem empfang hat eine zweite runde
[Musik]
polina sprung ins modegeschäft ohne die
traditionelle north bridge venture im
eigenen land immer zu acht verschiedene
country wie ein hohn klingen
[Musik]
der westküste entlang fahren nach ex
foto köster liegt in kalorien
es ist mindestens so schön mit great
barrier reef und noch viel besseren
ich habe mich der meeresbiologie danny
webb abgemacht geschafft von
nationalparkbehörde von ingolf
kopierschutz von der riesige walheim
rief lagen
pünktlich zum sonnenuntergang
ja das ist unser lieblingsplatz hier
oben wir haben bereits einige male
gesehen
sie sind vorbei geschwommen von hier
oben
toll und dazu barbecue mit freunden und
familie
ja wir treffen uns zu garnelen und
champagner und halten ausschau nach den
bayern
[Musik]
die denny herzig laden sie am nächsten
morgen betreut begleitet und mit blick
scheine eher mittelbar schwimmen
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen liegt vor der küste
einige ausflugsboot in aix muss endlich
in den letzten jahren einige touristen
name oft für marketing von der wahrheit
spezialisiert
konkurrenz unter den touristen baudisch
groß umso wichtiger seien kontrollen die
denn begleitet regelmäßig wahl hans
flick und kontrolliert richtlinie karte
war jedes brot brötchen lizenz und ist
eine strikte verhaltenskodex unterstellt
[Musik]
obwohl neopren zeug zum schutz vor
ausstrahlung
das oberstes ziel von danny ist der
schutz vor der wahrheit
der captain vom touristenboot will
mittel für marketing von der haar ja
geld verdienen
die dänischen papier kontrolliert ich
stehe mit locker und freundschaftlich
der boss ist aber die denn wenn sie
unregelmäßigkeiten bezüglich richtlinie
entdeckt riskierte frau stellte die
lizenz zu verlieren
langsam spüren das flugzeug war heuer
und meldeten captain die genaue position
[Musik]
wir sportler marseille holte
wer darf er ist imho nur verhindern so
dass ein kind verschwindet und will mir
ein mindestabstand von 4 mio
[Musik]
ein deutscher nur ein paar wenige meter
von mir weg
[Musik]
nicht wenige sturz mit einer einzigen
flossenschlag dürfte es ab in dunkelheit
vom indischen
[Musik]
wechsel bei uns gut
werde ich so schnell nicht gerade wenn
ich entschieden mich unglaublich
ja ich habe ihn gesehen aber nur kurz
war wohl ein schneller kern hat ziemlich
schnell malaria sind einzelgänger und
wandert der prüfstein
die denn überwacht dass die
touristenboote nicht lange geblieben
der captain muss immer wieder andere
haustiere maschine halt vor dem flugzeug
erspart
wann hast du deinen ersten mal gesehen
vor etwa zehn jahren und das war der
moment in dem du dich in die tiere
verliebt hat diese tiere haben mich
schon in der schule fasziniert aber ich
hätte mir nie erträumt dass sich der
einst in mindelo rief mit ihnen arbeiten
werde
als zwölfjährige konnte ich mir das
nicht vorstellen
es ist fantastisch ich finde sie sind
mehr wale als haie
nein das meinen alle es sind richtige
haie und nicht mit dem wall verwandt
aber der charakter scheint zu hoch
wenn wir sie sehen sind sie nicht auf
nahrungssuche
sie wärmen sich gemütlich an der
meeresoberfläche auf ich habe die wahl
ja schon ein gefräßiger ekstase erlebt
wenn sie hungrig waren sie schießen mit
offenem maul das wasser dann wirst du
auf keinen fall in ihrer nähe sein
nicht weil sie angreifen würden aber sie
sind so schnell und kräftig du könntest
ihnen kaum ausweichen dort drüben dreht
er seine runden
also bin ich
viele sind
[Musik]
obwohl war ja so imposant sind weiß man
sehr wenig relevant route und iris
porsche halte die tenne vermutet dass
sie ein großer teil von ihrem lover in
großer die affinger verbringen
[Musik]
meeresbiologische und jetzt auch jetzt
was sie will dritte floss vom haus
fotografieren
die wii spiel jeden der individuell die
denn gerade der identifizieren und so
die population kontrollieren
[Musik]
die aller faszination und begeisterung
mir gehört
kommst du nochmals rein nein okay
nein mir ist schlecht
ich behalte doch um vage und nicht
wirklich seetauglich minijob ich hoffe
und ich träume von wahrheit
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen habe ich mich erholt
inzwischen stand 11 30 400 kilometer auf
dem zähler
weiter geht's entlang vor der westküste
[Musik]
zum sony am nächsten morgen erreichen
die berühmte pinnacles
[Musik]
er fasst sie in der fz ist versteh
unterwasserlandschaft der held
wenn wir so rechts der spitze weil es im
proberaum
die volksschule sind vor den vorjahren
standen dazu mal die stadt sachlich all
das unter wasser
[Musik]
holzgreve
langsam matches mini reiste menzel ich
besitze zwei monate unterwegs
also bilder nämlich mit und die blieben
unvergessen
ich frage mich wir warten manche gefragt
war so endlos schienen der landschaft
boxen
familie heimat keine die geborgenheit im
bett in der hohenberger
[Musik]
nach 12 300 kilometer ist jetzt fertig
vor zwei wochen in meinem team in rüti
zh im outback gestoppt
[Musik]
vom controlling
30 40
ich beziehe morgen aus stroh lexy &
tabellen safina was andere politik treu
habe mal so glücklich wie im lucky
country
[Musik]
hermann erklärt warum ich mit ihrer
liegenschaft abgesteckt
[Musik]
und ich manche kann erklärt bei mir
gezeigt hat dass märklin ist auch müssen
[Musik]
sind manche australier glücklich also
wer in der schweiz
nein ich glaube nicht
mehr erwartet die reise im wahrsten sinn
von bord horizont
und ich weiß jetzt weltoffenheit und
erneut vereisen gewinn chance bewahrt
vom eigenen lucky country 19
[Musik]